gary is in fantasy football with michael
rappaport and now i understand gary you
are uh the victim of michael rappaport
what's going on well we played each
other this week and he had you know
he had a day yesterday that's like
unlike any other probably maybe one of
the highest scoring days and
i like i wasn't even following the
scores and at one point
there was something about that my
[ __ ] was leaking or something because
of all he had done to me
and i was just like whatever here is a
note that rappaport sent to gary wow
i power [ __ ] baba bowie i really did
it
diaper time
another email to gary busted that
monkey's ass
open jd you took a beating last week
maybe i should play a couple of these
oh my god yes he did no he did he [ __ ]
me last week
he did unlike uh gary you don't ever
take his phone calls right
you don't he keeps leaving your
voicemails and that seems to frustrate
him that you won't pick up
he won't leave me voiceovers now he'll
send me voice texts
like he'll like record a message and
then text that to me to make sure
that i hear what he has to say this was
the first message here you go
jd you [ __ ] and that's the last time i'm
ever calling you jd your name is
jamie [ __ ] you got that long
hair
okay tuck it nice
and pat the [ __ ] what i said pat
the [ __ ] okay pat it nice
i want that little [ __ ] kitty cat of
yours i want it tucked
okay and i want that [ __ ] meow
meow okay what is that is that so bad
tuck it under i'm gonna kick your
[ __ ] ass all weekend long
this is uh what you hear your first
night in prison
i imagine michael tweeted about beating
jd
jd replied with the tweet telling
michael he can stop calling him because
he won't pick
up that made michael crazy and led to
this upsetting message
let me tell you something you [ __ ]
squirt you don't [ __ ] tell me
stop texting you stop voicemailing you
you little [ __ ]
okay you put that [ __ ] lipstick on
mistress
mistress jamie okay you put that [ __ ]
red lipstick on
okay you brush your [ __ ] hair back
okay so i could hold it
you understand me okay and wrap my
[ __ ] arms around you you [ __ ] red
lipstick
[ __ ] [ __ ] you wow i think 200
i made 200 a year for this abuse
michael was really pissed jd tried to
vote him out of the league a few years
ago
listen to this i'll never [ __ ] forget
you tried to [ __ ] kick me out of this
league
and what happened today i stuffed that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i opened that [ __ ] balloon knot
that's me spitting on it
you [ __ ] that's called spitting on the
balloon knot
you don't want to [ __ ] answer my
[ __ ] phone calls i know where you
live
like when you're out walking your dog i
could walk my [ __ ] dog
in the same neighborhood ain't no
[ __ ] rules against that
look me up [ __ ] look me the [ __ ]
up
i'm known for that kind of [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] i spit on it again
i spit on your glasses now your glasses
have spin on them you [ __ ]
you suck the bangles suck your fantasy
football team sucks
your [ __ ] glasses suck your haircut
sucks
okay your [ __ ] beard sucks okay
and your big [ __ ] teeth suck okay you
got [ __ ]
teeth almost almost as despicable as
[ __ ] gary's
you big tooth fluoride [ __ ] i beat your
[ __ ] ass
go to sleep [ __ ] and pat that little
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god jd do you have a dog
no
but i mean he takes that fantasy
football very seriously
oh yeah very seriously oh yeah too
serious